嘿，你昨天有沒有看到 Singularity Hub 上面那個關於 AI 戒指的文章？我覺得那個創新點很有趣耶。
有看到，我覺得這款 AI 戒指，把手語翻譯這件事，從傳統模式帶到一個新的層次。它把微型穿戴裝置跟 AI 結合，能做到即時翻譯，這點出乎我意料。
對啊，就覺得，這麼小的戒指，怎麼能解決這麼複雜的溝通問題？我以前想像的翻譯器都很大一台，或者至少像手機那麼大，沒想到現在可以縮小到戒指。
這點確實不容易做到。一般公司或人可能不會這樣想，因為大家習慣從功能面去思考，覺得翻譯需要大量的感測器和處理能力，很難塞進這麼小的體積裡。
你說的沒錯，所以才會覺得它特別。它顛覆了大家對「翻譯裝置」的想像，把一個原本可能很顯眼、甚至有點尷尬的輔助工具，變成日常穿戴的一部分。
嗯，它具體是怎麼做到的呢？文章裡有提到，這七枚 AI 戒指可以讀取兩種手語中 100 個常見手勢，還能自動補齊句子。這代表它不是單純識別，還具備語境判斷能力。
對，就是這個「自動補齊句子」讓我很好奇。這表示它不只是辨識單一動作，而是能夠理解語意流暢性，讓對話更自然，這就很像真人翻譯了。
從經營者的角度來看，這裡面有個很重要的學習點。就是當你把複雜的技術微型化，並且融入到日常生活中，就能創造出以前難以想像的應用場景和市場。
沒錯，而且它不只是技術創新，更是人文應用突破。它讓聽障社群的溝通變得更無障礙，這點比單純追求商業效率更有意義，也更容易打動人心。
是的，它展現了 AI 在促進人類連結和社會包容方面的巨大潛力。這對於創業者或主管來說，是個很好的啟發：不要只盯著那些看得見的、大眾化的需求。
像這種為特定社群解決痛點的創新，雖然市場可能沒那麼廣，但一旦做出來，就會非常有價值，而且忠誠度會很高，因為它真的改善了人們的生活品質。
對一般上班族來說，這個概念也可以帶到工作或生活中。想想看，我們有沒有一些習以為常的工作流程，其實可以透過微小的創新，讓它更順暢、更有效率？
比如說，我們開會時，如果能有某種小工具，自動把大家發言的重點整理出來，或者把關鍵字視覺化，那整個會議效率就會大大提升，而且不會有遺漏。
或者在團隊合作時，如果有個小型裝置能即時偵測團隊的情緒，或是在溝通上給予一些非侵入性的提示，可能就能減少很多誤會。
對啊，就像這個 AI 戒指，它把原本需要透過外顯、有時甚至有點阻礙的方式，轉化成無形、自然融入的形式。我們在工作或生活上，也可以多思考怎麼讓「輔助」變得更隱形。
所以，重點不在於技術多高深，而是如何把複雜的技術，巧妙地應用到那些看似微小，卻能大大提升體驗的環節。這樣做的價值，常常會被低估。
沒錯，下次我們遇到一個需要解決的問題，或許可以想想，有沒有什麼「戒指大小」的解決方案，可以讓事情變得更好？
很有意思的角度。我想，這就是這款 AI 戒指帶給我們最大的啟發吧。